they don't they they hear so much about
Muslims and violence Isis and all this
stuff you look at the number of people
Isis ago I don't like Isis okay I don't
support Isis you know there's lots of
things they do that are absolutely
unacceptable but if you look at the
number of people let's say that the
Egyptian government now has in prison
number of people that the Egyptian
government killed since the coup of 2013
I mean you're talking about thousands
and thousands of civilians you know may
be dozens of thousands of people in
prison wrongly being tortured and raped
in prison I mean is you know what what's
the difference between that and Isis
really I mean you know you're talking
about governments or organizations that
kill thousands of innocent people in
prison or torture thousands of innocent
people but no one thinks about here's
how about Isis they don't think about
other things that you know so they're
convinced that somehow Islam leads to
these evils but there's exactly the same
number of evils or mounted evil being
done by something that's obviously on
that's not justified by Islam at all
we're not even attempting to justify
itself so I think this is you know Isis
exists because the United States invaded
Iraq and destroyed all the institutions
that country and left it a complete mess
that's that's a fact okay
Isis doesn't exist because of Islam
because Islam was in Iraq before 2003
and there was no Sunni extremists there
was no sunny terrorism there was no Isis
before 2003 this result this emerged in
Iraq at because of the United States
invasion that's what caused Isis its
Lomb didn't cause Isis but if you look
at the US media it's obsessed with
getting people to talk about Islam the
cause of Isis Isis because of Islam why
does it do that because the function of
media and government is to prevent
people from actually in this case
prevent them from actually reflecting on
the actual causes of this phenomenon
which is the United States unjust war
mongering because if people sat there
and said hey wait a second we got talked
into invading this country it was a
total disaster now we have this Isis
business then they might say maybe we
shouldn't go and invade countries the
next time we're asked by our government
to support a war that's not what the
kind of power elite or the military
media industrial complex once they'd
want people thinking like that so they
have
sit and place to focus on some other
cause it was cuz of Islam they don't
want Americans actually thinking about
really cause these things so when I when
I what I tell you you know Muslims or
even non-muslims about this is don't be
bamboozled by what you see on TV it's
very simple I mean I know it's obvious
but just because people say stuff a lot
on TV doesn't make it true